Daisy you get to use your lovely English
voice okay throughout okay John not so
much no I have an American accent he's
so good it's a credit your accent is so
big I thank you I mean I tried it in the
British but I didn't work out I'm a
stormtrooper and they have say yeah I'm
just like John I don't think it's right
let's go with America but what if you
hadn't been able to do America yeah I
would have been not have a beard so that
kids and things don't think you're
obi-wan Kenobi yeah just to hide from my
obi-wan Kenobi Ness well is that because
no do I have chased after kids who don't
believe that I am obi-wan Kenobi once I
once I saw in somebody's eyes once I was
driving my kids to school and I was at a
stop sign and some this is the thing
about la you get like 16 or 15 and a
half year old driving cars blue pastures
at a stop sign and I thought that was
very dangerous because it was and I
pulled up I've raced after him and my
daughter with Nick don't dad don't I
will and I pulled up beside him and I
started raging and you idiot you [ __ ]
idiot like I said my daughter's
recording like that I saw in his eyes I
saw the that's [ __ ] obi-wan Kenobi
I'm Tina Fey you've given us a your
printer's laughs yeah I was a big star
Wars fan as a kid and I've dressed up
like Princess Leia for TV shows just I
was always getting like to get out of
jury duty I would dress up like Princess
Leia you want to meet some perverts who
you've never met before come talk to you
like it people there's a real specific
they're gonna be before for one now oh
yeah that's dope
yeah they make it oh no there's nothing
to do with it just what well there's a
couple things are with it and why don't
we be give it to me that's all in the
office would be you know be really bare
you gonna be worth more
oh yeah if my son had that I would be
the capital does no I have the real one
at home that has bad [ __ ] right
here yeah you Toby jugs Kenobi yes I
love this one
you did princess panty Padme yes perhaps
our favors this is dawn as Grandmaster
Oscoda
[Laughter]
so Daisy how long did you have to keep a
secret of actually being in it that
you've got the part
three months no three months you have to
tell someone in three months did you
know that oh I told them when I got cast
I told the taxi driver
I released it the other day I did tell
the taxi driver I can't lie to you I did
know my family didn't know the taxi
driver did just like me I've just been
cast in Star Wars he was just like all
right mate so he can tell first Pacey I
told my sister and my mum when I came in
and then I told my dad and then he was
kind of sleeping he went Jesus Christ I
think your mum told me something and I
was like no no no I told you that and
then he went oh I was always more of a
trek fan that's a bad father
yeah they had no clue what Star Wars was
but they were great that I got a job
there he's not gonna you nearer but okay
look them in the eyes and tell him oh
wait wait for the music I love you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what would make your kids
really jealous that is if you just posed
with a lightsaber with thin that would
actually make them very gel to do it
I've got one I've got one in Manchester
United at red okay you've got David
Beckham
you've got your match
I just wanted to meet you make
the heart of this book of course is the
love affair between yourself and
Harrison now given that it did happen 40
years ago I was just remembered what was
that but also that it has caused a
sensation you would think the people
gotta go Oh two young actors yeah of
course they had an affair but this is
called auctions it 400000 news services
picked it up I achieve a little
embarrassing but here's the thing I do
find this extraordinary so 40 years ago
you have this affair over the months of
the movie and you say you literally
never spoke about it again I think I'm
seeing it more on everything I became
friends with his second wife then and so
we saw each other a lot and no I could
literally remember three times that we I
of course made some oblique reference to
it and he was now he's gonna have to
talk about it for the rest of his life
that's what you I never thought of that
and leave it you brand now and now I
feel more you guys a quote on the front
good and where there are nerd fans there
are nerd tattoos and I believe you
you've had your first nerd tattoo
yes yes I came across a male who had the
character of gin tattooed onto his who
are you he's a new tattoo yeah me me at
me I've been tattooed onto his calf
really worried
I know we've got a picture off a donkey
God don't leave we can show that
oh it sees there's his ankles so it's
actually kind of an oddly good likeness
for a tattoo yeah I'm just worried about
what happens when the hair grows back
[Laughter]
due to people are you one of those
actors yeah yeah but I mean I think I
think I think a lot of us yeah don't we
I mean it's either music or it's or it's
it's bits voices or tons of voices I
mean you know I used to muck around with
dictaphones at school for ages and just
you know do interpretations on persons
or people and create characters and it's
just sort of having in the air it's part
of what we do I guess I mean even if
it's not a real person just to imitate
or have empathy with a state or a human
being of any general you were doing -
back at during the clip what I'm with
the - back of being just natural magic
that's one of my favorite 'back a moment
is just that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
graham norton here if you'd like to see
even more stuff like that then hit
subscribe or don't it's a free world but
I know what I do in that situation